so if you have a complex number in the
trigonometric form like we have here all
you have to do is take the nth root of
the R value so if it's you know the cube
root this is going to be three the cube
root and then you're going to take the
angle plus 2 pi K divided by whatever
route you're taking so if it's a cube
root and it's going to be three if it's
the fourth root it's going to be four
and so on but K is always going to be 0
1 2 all the way up to n minus 1 so if
you're taking the cube root you're
actually gonna get three answers K is
going to be 0 1 and 2 if you're taking
the fourth root there's going to be four
answers and it's going to be 0 1 2 3 so
whatever route you're taking or get that
many solutions and you're going to start
at the K values 0 1 2 all the way up to
n minus 1 so let's take a look at an
example and we'll walk through it so say
we want to find the cube roots of this
complex number which is in trigonometric
form what we're going to do is since
we're taking the cube root were to take
the cube root of 8 which is 2 and then
what we're going to do is we're going to
take the cosine of 2 pi over 3 plus 2 pi
K oops 2 pi K all right all divided by
in this case 3 because we're taking the
cube root plus I sine 2 PI over 3 plus 2
pi K all divided by 3 ok so now all we
have to do is substitute in k equals 0 1
& 2 so we're going to get three answers
so our first answer is going to be 2
cosine K is 0 0 times 2 pi is 0 so this
is just going to be 2 PI over 3 which is
2 PI over 9 plus I sine 2 PI over 9 okay
the next one is going to be 2 cosine K
now k is 1 so we have 2 pi which is
actually 6 PI over 3 plus 2 PI over 3 is
8 PI over 3 divided by 3 is 8 PI over 9
plus I sine
eight PI over nine and then the third
one is going to be two cosine K is two
now so that's four pi which is 12 PI
over 3 plus 2 PI over 3 is 14 PI over 3
divided by 3 is 14 PI over 9 plus I sine
14 PI over 9 and that's it so those are
your three solutions and what you can do
is you can distribute the two okay and
you can translate this back into the
standard form the a plus bi form of a
complex number
so again just